todos los mandatarios que asistieron a
la cumbre iberoamericana coincidieron en
una cosa la reivindicación del acceso
equitativo y universal a la vacuna
contra el jove 19 a pesar de proceder de
distintos espectros políticos los
líderes que participaron en el encuentro
semipresencial rechazaron el acceso
desigual a los fármacos y el retraso del
mecanismo kóvacs además luis arce
presidente de bolivia pidió la
liberación de las patentes las poderosas
transnacionales farmacéuticas que tienen
patentes sobre los diagnósticos
medicamentos y vacunas deben liberarlas
y hacerlas de dominio público o emitir
autorizaciones voluntarias sin costo
para lograr un acceso real de parte de
todas las naciones sin excepción
recordando el carácter global de la
pandemia se apostó por la inmunización
mundial para acabar con el virus
debemos asumir además que nadie está a
salvo hasta que todos estemos a salvo y
por grande tenemos que avanzar hacia una
inmunización en vistas a la situación
españa se comprometió a donar entre un
5% y un 10% de sus inoculantes américa
latina'
por su parte la ups señaló que los
países ricos poseen hasta cinco veces
más vacunas de las que necesitan y
advirtió sobre el aumento de contagios
en sudamérica
pero en ningún sitio los contagios son
tan preocupantes como en sudamérica
donde los casos están incrementando en
casi todos los países en américa latina
es actualmente el epicentro de la
pandemia acumula alrededor de 27
millones de contagios y 873 mil muertes